to call this man versatile is an
understatement his new movie Olympic
dreams and theaters right now is a sweet
film that you will love to see my kids
love him as the voice of Gunther and he
is so versatile that he played the role
of douche on TV and film and Parks and
Rec and sausage party good to see you
Nick Kroll good to see you man I'm not
wrong right I know it's probably one of
the few people who's played two
different characters named the douche
that's right and you uh you crush them
both thank you you're very welcome so
natural but let's let's start off by
talking about this movie that that
premiered at the Sundance Film Festival
a couple of winters ago and is now in
theaters you shot it entirely at the
Pyeongchang Olympic Games a Winter
Olympic yeah in 2018 how in the world
did you pull that off well Alexi Pappas
and Jeremy Teixeira the filmmaker couple
I made it with Alexei is a summer
Olympian and they got a grant from the
Olympic Committee to be like
artist-in-residence and they decided
they were gonna try to shoot something
so about two weeks before the Olympics
they came to me I was writing big mouths
and they were like do you want to go to
the Olympics and try to shoot this movie
it's just the three of us we can't
there's no crew and it just seemed like
an amazing I've always been a big fan of
the Olympics the first Olympics I
remember were in Seoul and in 88 that
was like Dan Jannsen and Bonnie Blair
and like Debbie Thomas all those and
that so I was the idea of going to Korea
to see it in person was exciting and it
seemed like an interesting challenge and
because they were sponsored by the
Olympic Committee we had kind of access
to stuff that nobody else has access to
at the games usually when you watch the
Olympics you sort of see the gold medal
matches or like the their plight to get
to the Olympics but I don't actually see
the living the living the Olympic
Village the dining hall the Med Center
the gyms like what what goes on for
those athletes while the games are going
on the Olympics are very pretty
controlling of what gets out there and
they allowed us to go inside of the
Olympic Village and the three of a shot
of feature film inside of it and there
are in Olympic dreams in theaters near
you right now and there are
actual Olympians who are yeah not to say
extras but making cameos are playing
yeah not playing themselves per sera
they are playing themselves for the most
part they're all playing themselves the
only person who's sort of not but sort
of is is Gus Kenworthy he was the only
athlete that we had contacted before the
movie if you remember Gus is a slope
style skier he's a metal he's metal
before he he's the first he and Adam rip
and we're the first openly gay athletes
for the American team great actor made a
hilariously good actor which is so
annoying that an athlete gonna be that
good and all the other actors in the
movie are all Olympians so we would just
grab people out of the athletes village
you know in the dining hall whatever be
like hey you want to be in a movie
and because my character is a dentist I
would sort of interview people while I
was doing giving them dental exam right
so it was like you know the 16 year old
New Zealand kid the youngest male
competing the Olympics a girl who didn't
qualify but then someone got injured and
got a call in the middle of the Olympics
to fly to Korea to compete two days
later or kidding yeah so you get to kind
of see all of these and we really it's a
story of this girl Penelope about what
it's like when you're an Olympic athlete
you've trained your whole life for this
moment
and then it happens and you're like what
do I do now you know so Penelope is a
young cross-country skier played by a
real-life Olympic runner yes named Alexi
Pappas whose husband is the director yes
and then you're the third if you will
person in yes as a volunteer dentist
yeah who kind of what falls in this we
kind of love story it's a little kind of
lost in translation before sunrise and
they're really just two people at this
crossroad in their lives of like you
know she's competed and now she doesn't
know what to do he's you know in and out
of a relationship but as these two
people are kind of a lone you know
that's the thing you're at the Olympics
and you're surrounded by all of these
people in the athletes village but a lot
of people are kind of bored and alone
and they don't know what to do at their
time the condom tray was always empty in
the bathroom
the Olympics that was my next question
yeah yeah stuff going down I was not a
part of any of it but there was well
you're just a volunteer dad it was just
a volunteer dad but it was create was
really it's just sort of it's just a
while it's like being in Finland is
there something exciting about being the
Olympics we got to because we were there
with the Olympic Committee we got to be
right there like on the sidelines or you
know on the right next to the rink and
and you got access to sinks like seeing
someone do skeleton you know like that
ice luge kind of headfirst seeing
someone do that in person is wild
watching someone sprint jump down on a
little sled down an ice slide at 60 70
miles an hour is crazy when I see that I
wonder how does that get invented that
has to be invented out of sheer boredom
by somebody one day right you know
here's what we're gonna do yeah you know
nothing to do today let's just go
headfirst down some sort of slide down
that bobsled seems like there's some
protection from catastrophic injury what
if we just took all of that away and
said people down headfirst they're doing
that's what skeleton is it is crazy I
mean you watch that stuff in person
you're like these people are insane
so what did you learn about that you
might not already have known about the
Olympics that you did use I mean again
it is so rare it is I know it again when
you get notes for a film from County or
whatever first narrative film ever shot
in a real Olympic athlete village I mean
like yeah I mean this this doesn't get
the axis doesn't happen and you don't
usually pull it off if you ya know I
just was you know I think it was really
like being a being with these athletes
like because with this it's a story of
this girl's what am I gonna do with the
rest of my life but then you hang out
with the athletes and you know we
they're really all going through that
because they're also like think about it
you're like I've competed am I gonna
come back in four years you know like of
course they're gonna see and throughout
is this it you know can you imagine
being 22 years old and being like is
this the end of my career that I've
spent 15 years right every day all day
training for you know it's like look
football players at you know basketball
player is softball whatever it's not it
doesn't necessarily end it today they
have a shorter run but it's still pretty
crazy to sort of
Seve of is this it is this over hmm Nick
Kroll here on the Rich Eisen show and
this might come across as a
disrespectful question to elicit a
disrespectful answer you got is not
was there any event that you saw you
thought you know I mean I could medal
and I think you know what I don't know
if you watched curling but like I feel
like people got in the country star to
get into curling this past time I mean
the Americans did very well yeah and I
was like you know they all have real
jobs the curl that's an interesting
they're not full-time athletes they all
have real jobs they're like they're like
NFL officials yes exactly and with all
due respect to the NFL officials and
curlers and curlers and to the Houston
Astros it's a good place to announce
that I am I do I am partly responsible
for the stealing houses what did you do
I provided the Astros with trash can did
yeah well very connected to the Houston
that was not covered in the
commissioners report the way read that
at all and I said with the trash can so
I was like it's just a piece of metal
you know and so they didn't think that
too much was it rubber anyway I mean it
could have been that - are you gonna get
thrown at and spring training games no
this whole thing at least we now we
found out how it all states you can it's
broken here on the Rich Eisen show Nick
Kroll responsible for the Houston Astros
that's the headline that goes the
Olympic dream that gooders yeah right
now so the curling though you got you do
curling uh-huh I went skiing this past
weekend I don't think I could do any
skiing events okay I'm not interested in
hurting myself ice dancing I think I
would if I found the right partner I
could be a great ice dancer if you're
interested if you want to be the first
same-sex ice dancing couple I would do
that with you right okay well actually I
don't skate very well that's fine I'll
carry the heavy load I played hockey for
one year okay yeah skeleton that was
interesting one of our athletes talked
about it's called head shoulders knees
and toes that's how they turn its a head
is like four turns shoulders and it's
levels of how big you have to make a
turn it's it's it's pretty crazy did
they still they sing the song the
children's song I was like yeah I never
you're going down a nice slide at 70
miles an hour you're just gonna copy
I'll get you the car they crawl here on
the Rich Eisen show best comedian or
actor out of the uncle drew gang that
you saw was which was who see web Chris
Webb was so funny as the preacher he was
great Shaq is naturally hilarious Nate
Robinson is a rascal what do you mean
both he's just a rascal like wherever
you are like you know you'd be in
between takes and he would be off like
playing music and dancing and like he
would just be he's just a bit of a
rascal okay um he also dunked on over
Shaq not like dunked on check but like
jumped over there's a video of Nate
Robinson jumping over Shaq did you see
that in person I did no I miss that I
guys saw the video of it Kairi good
actor okay
Reggie Miller I get to be on the
sidelines coach because I was when I was
growing up I was a Knicks fan I watched
I was at a couple of those Knicks and
Pacers games yeah and to be able to talk
trash against Reggie Miller as he was
missing threes from the corner was truly
one of the great events of my life Lisa
Leslie still still great fun watching it
was fun watching them all like Kyrie was
like you know he does that crazy spin
stuff on the layups and watching like
Lisa Leslie trying to learn and
understand Kyrie spin stuff was really
cool rail lil rel who I was kind of
opposite in the movie great guy who only
went one-on-one between you and I I
think if you watch him in the celebrity
all-star game this past weekend yes
it'll be pretty clear who would have win
one-on-one
[Music]
and just leave it at that I'll just
leave it at that
I have no I did watch that game and I
was like I'm so glad I'm not playing
this game
it would be terrifying there's you can't
you can't do well in that game could you
imagine if you play in that game and it
is terrifying I imagine just like
throwing out a first pitch like doing
anything Jessica with truck I mean
anything physical with the with
everybody watch yes and then you have
Stephen a Smith berating you as your
coach like now that would be the
ultimate that would be the absolute yeah
but I mean that's those are some of my
most erotic fantasies so just that idea
Nick Kroll here on the Rich Eisen show
and my kids knew you were on here right
now Gunther I mean how many kids do you
meet that you you're asked to do the
voices of for them you know good amount
and sometimes even when unprompted I'll
just play hello how are you today we're
working on the next one there's a second
one coming to ya sing to is coming test
yep it's so fun that movie really I
really sing is I mean I'm sure you have
like all the movies your kids watch but
what I do here is like people like I
like to I can re-watch that one honestly
yeah you know we went through it we went
through a big sing rip Todd yeah yeah it
was a con constantly yeah it's good it's
this really sweet movie it's a great
it's a very sweet one so I'm the
opposite of sausage party you know you
see you see stuff around town and
billboards yeah and the kids will see it
right and they see something like that
they assume it's for them yeah and it's
one well having one if there's nothing
quite a moment when you're driving
around and somebody from a car seat says
dad can we see sausage party you see
that are and that in the squared yeah no
yeah not to urate naturally you're eight
and then it's fine
that's parenting right there yeah that's
parenting right there that's good
parenting for sure now and do you no
longer do fantasy football cuz the
league's done or
we sort of thought you know we did
obviously we did it with I did it on a
show like in the show but we also had a
league amongst the guys in the show and
I haven't I've sort of fallen off a
little bit imagine I mean if you've done
it for so long
I did it and I it was fun when we were
doing inside show but then it got
stressful and I don't know what did
useful I don't know it's just like you
know I mean a lot of the stuff on the
show was real like that what we would
call the tinker-stinker it's like you
know I live on the west coast so that
it's that 9:45 wake up go to the
bathroom you got 15 minutes before first
kickoff to make some last-minute
terrible decisions taker stink or like
drunk drunk trades late night like make
some major moves at like 1:30 in the
morning in bed before you go to bed you
know you you know you go like man you
know pick up
I also pardon DeBartolo I think I should
mention that as well i pardon anybody
that's now that's a new fantasy team
name is pardoning Tabar hard-partying
debarred oh yes that's it but I
shouldn't sit here and say what's so
stressful about it because there are
times yeah where I lose in a fantasy man
ok yeah ok
and it's a Monday night loss it's
guttered like your head and then you're
behind and you lose yeah and I am I have
trouble getting asleep and I have to sit
here and walk through the positives in
my actual life yes to say what is the
matter with you like I've actually had
to go through that mental assures I
think I got a little tired of that and I
just was like and also like I hated
losing like lesoire who played talked on
the show never had an auto-draft and
then didn't do anything and like
literally never set a lineup and would
still win this is insane this is right I
know
alright also the amount of injuries now
it's like how do you keep a team
together like I don't know
alright it's I find it very so I would I
would get back into it I don't know do
you do the basketball or any other no no
no no balls this much football it is it
is too much I mean the best
Derr a Thwaite from the league would be
who the best athlete the actor actor
that came on the show and did it was
always funny sizzle je je je wat like
that was one you realize like and the
same hat goes with Olympic dreams you
realize like JJ Watt came in on a Monday
this was like season two or three or
that he was he was the second or third
year in league came up came in on a
monday did a scene or to him was fine
then it was like the week of the ESPYs
he like did probably like two
commercials right a bid for the ESPYs
and came back on Friday oh boy and was
markedly better as an actor huh and I
think like the people who these folks
who become professional athletes like
there they learned so fast
the reason they're professional athletes
is because there are a lot of
athletically gifted people but they're
only so many people who can absorb
information process it and then spit it
back out effectively right and it's like
JJ Watt is going to learn to be an actor
just like he learns like you know the
new the new offensive set for the team
he's playing that week and the same goes
I think with what I found an uncle drew
Webb you know like those guys just are
learning so fast and the same goes with
the athletes that I worked with on
Olympic dreams those guys and and women
are just like learning so fast they're
used to being on camera they're used to
processing things and putting it back
out and it's you know and then obviously
you know living for the moment you got
maybe one or two takes the Olympics yeah
one take oh it's crazy these athletes no
it's like you get one shot you really do
it's like watching and and you realize
how focused they have to be I mean their
their bodies are machines but then it's
the mental focus that goes into it and
you can see you can see people who are
you know kind of floating away a little
bit and the ones who are focused and and
you know just trying to treat and how
they have to treat their bodies like you
know that was it dealing with Lexie
who's a long-distance runner and she was
like I need to nap myself I need to eat
this every day it's like they have to be
sewed regimented and how they treat
their body just like us right just like
us yeah I'm like I need to nap because
I've just had a sugar high and now I
need to eat chocolate when I wake up cuz
I'm tired from my nap look it's not just
anybody who can just provide trashcans
Willy
two teams that need the help you know if
you're in the Houston area and I have
some access trash cans available for
sale now if anybody's interested role at
Nick Kroll
hit me up DME I'm around I got smart
phones that are not being used anymore I
got everything you need Olympic dreams
and theaters now at Nick Kroll on
Twitter and Instagram thanks for coming
on bro thanks for having that snicker
all right here on the Rich Eisen show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app